so when we played that the other night
opening night in Denver yeah you were
excited yeah I mean but I was excited
because Meek Mill and Rick Ross M ra but
then they it's called Shaq and Kobe yeah
and so you know for me I know you on the
remix or something like that I heard
yeah I'm on the remix but I had I got
something for you brother I got
something I had I had to do something
for you I had to make a call when it was
coming out I was like why is my guys not
like he's part of MMG and all of that so
I had to make a call and then this what
happens when I make calls
call my make call this what happens this
what
Happ always you do a lot
[Music]
cityo all theams and
all yeah
sure how youing you good hey wait wait
we got you got got this is
bomie hold the whole team down you
he hold you down up
baby better believe it say so hey Shaq
you said you was part of MMG no you got
show
the man for real that's your first bomie
that's mayack music to the icon you
already know what it is all the legends
on the stage what's up
baby what's up you smoked that remix too
big sha on that you already know one
time for the OG you already know he been
he been showing love to Ros for many
years y'all already know man MC the MC
big homie you bring me some tissue you
going to make me cry no that's real like
this you give away a lot of gifts then
you know oh wait Ernie had a question
which one's Kobe and which one's Shaq
there it
is oh there it is yeah there it is I'm
from Philly so I definitely stand up
toes Philly represent Philly well yeah
no thank you to apprciate you represent
Philly well that means something to you
man it does because you
know Rick told me a story where he he
met me a long time ago and he gave me
his gave me his tape gave me his CD he
said I was nice to him but I REM met him
in 2006 cuz you know we want to be y'all
y'all want to be us so at the time we
was winning our championships hustling
was killing the streets and that was my
joint every time I rode to the game so
that song This fell helped me win that
championship in Miami and then we would
always see each other and it was love so
he sent me the remix first yeah I did
and I was in the studio and I was
messing around I just did something I
was like please like it please like I
actually had the same feeling with him
that I had with biggie because when
biggy was coming to the studio I went in
there like a hundred times I was like if
he don't like it I'm done so I sent it
to him and he said he's like big fell
that's nice and I was just messing
around with I was like you know bro you
need to sign me up to mg I was just
playing but one the Bigg you know what I
mean much love we we have some remix we
I got some of to remix but I see wait me
you going back to like you going back to
like the 2000 Meek you got the braids
you look like you back yeah I had to get
back gritty I need the fuzzy braids you
know I got to get back down and dirty
battle rap me I I want I want to rap and
you know you know they made like the
viral moment in life I want to use
talent to again you know how y'all love
to see Talent y'all talk about Talent me
and Ross coming to put on you know I
love to rap ER Let It Be know like if
you listen to the song has nothing to do
with sha and Co but what they're saying
sublimely yeah they're the most dominant
onew punch in the hip-hop I can say well
too never par to the goats Shaq and Kobe
took a SE the M mentality what you offer
to the game I even watch the playoffs
when I record every time I get in the
booth I throw the greatest moments on
and get in there and just SC in my M cuz
I go off the energy I watch y'all doing
on that Court when y'all got a million
people watching and I'm in that Booth I
might throw on the playoffs just to get
that feel right there so I can be on the
same energy time well I'm more it's an
honor to meet both of you Brothers I
want to just tell you man I you know I
live in Philly yeah see I know you Liv
there I just know you did a lot of live
in suburbs I've been going to jail my
whole life suburbs I've been in jail
watching the news and they be like
Charles Barkley has paid for a funival
in Philadelphia I don't forget stuff
like that it was like a the stuff you've
been doing man I'm so proud of you cuz I
I say I only to live in Philly during
the summer cuz it's too hot to be in
Arizona
Rich that's part of no just too hot to
be in Arizona so I'm in Philly for like
four months a year and I see all the
stuff you're doing man I'm proud of you
keep doing your thing yeah no thank you
thank you for giving back to my city too
get to that remix here let's
do I've been hot I don't get to chill
they know my paper high so I fit the
bill get it cutom at the dealer I fit
the will I can hear the money talking
like if it was Phil focus on communities
I wish to build when it's for the unity
that's when I drill they love me out in
Philly like I roll with Meek they treat
me like I'm Ricky when I'm on the beach
trying to stack another Billy hour it's
on the reach DDM I give the say then I
go capish go to Venice for the day I
might go Caprice Aristotle on the way
that's when I go to gree I'mma bring the
drama till I'm with the Mamba forign car
at arm I got it from wakanda Hing all
theas like I was Honda this is just a
reminder that I'm your
designer be I be ready to rap every
second on a moment you heard ER most
definitely ER appreciate bro one last
thing to say I'm about to kill him at
the hookah bar with
[Applause]
this that's I love you you going to be
any
here I
come we will take a break and come back
with more inside in just a second